[Music]
how are you how are you
we're waiting I'm no I'm good say we are
another episode to talk about the gym
doing things amongst a lot of other
things like choices which is a choice
everyone makes when they have to buy
underwear which is why you should bike
me under you early Fritz I had that
tattooed across my back don't it's never
too early for summer hey Kermit
we're podcasting on youtube.com slash
Angelia podcast could you back office
this episode is brought to you by Muse
the softest underwear in the game new
designs every month shipped right to
your door micro model fabric so soft so
sexy go to me Indies calm / Jenna Julian
right now get 20% off your first order
and let me tell you you will not buy
another pair of underwear that is not me
and these after you get your first pair
of manatees also they have a whole new
line of women's I think it's called the
barely-there collection it's a very very
cool collection all the time new designs
every proud sponsor the twist shame
great people got them bra let's girl you
know also make sure Karen doesn't
doesn't go unbanned boozled at the water
cooler the skim that's th es ki mmm
dot-com through your daily newsletter of
things that go on in the world condensed
into a nice email for you just the point
yes the bullet points right you don't
need the fluff you don't need all the
nonsense just the bullet points it's
absolutely free literally just
subscribed and it's in your email go to
the skin that's th es ki mmm calm /n
Julian and you can be entered for a
chance to win a $250 Visa gift card that
is not free that is 250 dollars in your
pocket oh [ __ ] it's opposite of free
well it's actually free plus $20 you
could go to all of garden multiple times
with that or you could literally not and
do anything else you can buy a cool
slick daddy shirt
guys Julian's a fanboy he's wearing a
doctor disrespect shirt it's named the
slick daddy club his doctor does this
like compress
yeah sounds like compressed it is how do
I fix it is it too low in your ears is
like compressed I'm going to the tube
for a sec no come back
oh he's under the table a little bit
yeah that's better I added the
compressor so we could yeah and I would
never distort I'm trying to like mess of
the settings I'm not an audio
professional but I'm trying to become
yes like a little more proficient or
making this sound good yes you I okay
you're the audio professional hire me
yeah I will make everything in your life
sound good I will literally boom your
life
oh [ __ ] I'll walk around without a boom
wait just pretending I'm doing it what
if I'm not consenting to you booming all
of my sound I don't I don't want to be
recorded why'd you hire me why am I here
then I mean if you think about it that's
basically what Google home does without
you knowing yeah [ __ ] conspiracy theory
doo doo doo doo you're listening dude
everyone's listening did you see that
video that popped up on reddit that was
like Facebook's listening to me to
target us for ads did you see that
probably I was like very reason like it
was like this guy he filmed a he thought
he had suspicions that they which rather
made the facebook app on your phone if
you have it delete it it's garbage it's
been proven time and time again to like
spy on you and listen to your microphone
when you're not even in the app or
whatever
really yeah so this guy in my opinion
I've deleted it a long time ago I don't
[ __ ] with that because I've heard so
many horror stories about the Facebook
app but this guy had suspicions that
Facebook was deletes it right now you
have on your phone yeah well [ __ ] anyway
this guy was like I think we're being
listened to by the Facebook app I don't
know where the suspicion like exactly
came from or whatever but I know he had
some of those suspicions so he was like
we don't have a cat I'm gonna put the
phone on the counter and talk to my wife
about needing cat food so they have this
like fake contrived conversation about
needing cat food and like oh we're out
of cat food we should go buy cat food
and soon like soon enough they go on the
app and there's an ad for say like how
long after no and it's also like an
edited video so you never know but I'm
just saying that was in the front page
of Reddit just a couple of days ago and
you be careful kids careful what you say
so I'm totally aware of that and I'm
also totally aware of like your eyesight
like your cameras and like on our
laptops and computer we buy those little
plastic things or you can just slide it
over and cover your camera because it is
possible for someone anytime you have an
electronic it's possible for someone to
just hack in there and look in whatever
yeah like sometimes if I'm just like
chilling and I'm like naked I'll
literally like tip my phone away from
these I'm like what if somebody's spying
on me but I had heard that like Facebook
app while it's open does some sketchy
[ __ ] so every time I need to use it I
instantly close it can it still do that
even if the app is closed that's the
question the background listening I
don't know I've had suspicions that not
personally but just from what I've heard
I don't even need to risk it get it off
my cat well because haven't they already
use like Google home or Amazon echo or
something for a crime investigation
laches comes actly all the person's name
come on come on now you say you're not
listening get him up out of here
well that video that like went viral to
about the the new one the little one was
like freaking out and like listening to
everything that the person was saying
they had logged it all like in a yeah
that was just a malfunction I guess and
Google responded like immediately but
still like you know it's listening to
you it has the capability it's
technology it's like the people's fear
about like their locks or you know with
the touch like if you change your front
door so to recognize your fingerprint or
something like that someone can hack
that the second that you turn it into a
piece of technology someone can hack it
much easier than the primitive way of
picking a lock or you just kick it in
either way taking a digital lock so to
speak is a lot easier right or even just
like your home security cameras it's
technology in theory someone can hack
that yes you know so that's pretty
terrifying I just like I don't trust
Mark Zuckerberg at all yeah he's
he's very untrustworthy have you seen
him picture excreted about his legs his
legs are going in when he walks
no his legs like dip in when he walks he
doesn't look like a lizard person it's
probably as a person this brings me to
like what I was talking about the other
day though sort of tangent here we're
living in black mirror world everything
around us is just more and more
increasingly like that was a bug excuse
what reminded me of us we were playing
HQ I'm sure a lot of you guys have heard
of it it's this really actually cool
Kris and chin showed us and snake showed
us when they were in town yeah it's
basically not where it please not spawns
it's not it's not a sponsor it's an app
that does a live trivia show through
your phone so basically you'll get an
alert you click on HQ the app and
there's twice a day and it looks similar
to like a periscope with the amount of
viewers the child child oven and this
and that and it's a guy in front of a
green screen in-studio clearly it's like
high production but he's talking and
reacting to chat he's there live and
he's giving trivia and you can win like
a sum of money it's been like 500 I
think yeah like Sunday they upped it to
like 2,500 and it's just getting bigger
because it's like 30 40 thousand people
playing at once yeah so we're sitting
like when they were all they got all
excited they all got this notification
for HQ and like what what's going on
they're like judging just play with us
play with us and I'm like what are you
guys playing like what is that they're
like it's HQ trivia it's a live trivia
show and I'm like okay what the [ __ ] and
they're like you can win real money and
I'm like all right I'm downloading it
now
yeah and it's perfectly in sync like if
you're in a room full of other people
it's perfectly no there's no laziness um
something about how they've compressed
their live streaming in their servers is
like the video is optimized for you to
watch it on a mobile screen or facing up
right so you play like that so there's
12 questions there's it's three multiple
choice they're just trivia questions
so usually I've only played a couple
times I get out by like around five or
whatever yeah but so then whoever
answers that all of them correctly up to
12 that sum of people will then split
$500 which I imagine will go up as time
goes on in their viewership rise
I can't believe really cool well first
of all I think the fact that it came out
of nowhere for me at least like our
friends showed us it and then I'm like
on the app and then there's already
30,000 people and it looks optimized
it's beautiful it works it's easy and
and I play it it's that simple the
questions go fast enough so the I don't
think you can really cheat unless you
had somebody hardcore cheating it'd be
very very difficult to cheat and I think
if they if there are cheaters that
happens and they'll figure out anti
cheat or whatever but but it's so long
do you think the whole thing is it only
lasts for like 10-15 minutes 12 to 15
minutes it's really cool something about
it feel so Blackberry so black marry
because they're all sitting at our
phones watching this guy he's there live
it's not a recording and he's live he's
reacting to chat he's God knows where
yeah right which is also part of the the
mysterious aspect of like what's
happening here but the fact that it's
like you know I'm watching twitch
streams and people are getting the
notice and they're like midstream
they're like oh it's HQ time and you're
listening in the back like Jeff played
in the back of history it's something
about like the control it has over
everyone playing and I'm obeying at the
time of trivia is very interesting and
it gives me that same like feeling of
like that black mirror feeling where
it's like it it's it's very techie but
it's also like right here in your hands
but also like giving access to all these
thousands of people on their phone to
play this game but who knows what's on
the back end of it who knows what's yeah
like you can you can go on forever with
these conspiracies about it because it's
just if you've played the game you'll
know what I'm talking about and if you
haven't I mean I would suggest trying
out it's very interesting experience
it's free you just create an account and
you play and it even says in the App
Store when you're dying it says winners
are given money through PayPal it says
PayPal in the app to like legitimize it
yeah I like the experience of like I'm
sure a lot of you have done this a
formulaic with your friend like us with
twitch streams we try really hard if
you're watching on something and I'm
watching on something the same twitch
stream will try and sync them up the
best that we can in order for the sound
to not be [ __ ] obnoxious it's really
hard to
that exactly even though that persons
live they say this is I've never had an
experience with that many people in one
room are watching the exact same thing
all on tiny screens and it's live and
there's there's literally no delay like
when you black married you're like we
can win money sounds like they're
speakers all over the room it's exactly
insane yeah like the other night what
200 people won so they all won like two
dollars but then there was one guy who
won 500 he was the last man standing out
of 30 thousand it's crazy it's very cool
it's really cool I'm excited here you
know your thoughts on it and also I'm
excited to see what happens with it cuz
it's so early you know Chris was saying
the guy who created vine the team behind
vine made it I think that's what Chris
said but I'd be interested to see at
least for me like whenever I find
something that's like cool and exciting
you know sometimes that lasts like a
week and sometimes that lasts like a
year so I'm excited to see like if I get
the the notification and I'm like
available to play it at like how long it
will be until I'm like no thanks or what
is really fun cuz so fast so fast in
live what if though this is like a
method of poaching some of the smartest
people on the internet and we're I'm
like the winners are grouped into this
category Oh dad we're now their phones
are tapped or something like that Wow
I'm just saying like it's it's crazy to
think about you have you have your
little asking you have people answering
predetermined questions that who knows
where the do questions are coming from
who knows what the the logic behind
having that specific set of questions
each round is I mean it may seem random
to us but it could be very calculated
you never know why there's certain
questions like why the question about
the rock is followed by a question about
jazz and then the question about a
mountain range and you're just like wait
a minute no do you need a stretch cuz
that's a reach like I don't want you to
pull them up how was that a reach how is
that a reason hey hey hey users can
submit questions so they say where's the
proof
how do we know I always thought that'd
be such a good idea because then you're
guaranteed to get one right yeah but but
how easy would it be for them to say
this user
Adam John one two three and submitted
but it's really a question that's
predetermined that they want to know if
there's intolerant
population on their smartphones maybe
but you you also like do they have
access to our demographics because I
didn't link my account like I didn't
link my Facebook or Twitter you just
make an account no no no so you could
make an anonymous account all they would
in theory be able to tell as maybe your
location it's true so like plus they
also don't know their demographic
they're like we want to see how many
American females age of like thirteen
fifteen you know the answer is or they
could just be slipping one little secret
question in there every once in a while
to see if anyone gets it right and
they're like hey why did that person get
this right I don't know they're all
though they're all pretty trivial
they're like stuff that you wouldn't
really know maybe not right now but this
could be this platform could be used for
that sort of thing I'm just saying this
is devil's advocate here okay
the platform I agree with you the
platform like that could be is for
something that feels like right now I
don't think it is right now I'm just I'm
honestly having fun with the idea cuz it
like nothing has made me feel so black
memory on my own phone before yeah well
I I agree and I disagree because the
iPhone 10 opening with your face that's
very black Mary black Mary have you seen
the I think they're like infrared videos
people have taken when they're using
face ID and you can see all the dots on
their face being projected because it
has a dot projector no millions of tiny
dots mapping out your face dots
no um I just think it's interesting
because in all those deep conspiracy
videos that I watched it I really liked
those and I've shared a lot of the
theories with you guys you remember that
like the Google blood watch and [ __ ]
like they were saying that snapchat
basically by creating filters and
recognizing your face and that kind of
thing up in your face it's mapping
everyone's face to face it lady says
we're basically giving Apple like an
exact map of our faces
yeah that's crazy it is crazy but you
know what by now like everyone's used a
snapchat lens I know
this is the conspiracy though is that
for the sake of convenience and for you
know our own pleasure we're buying these
products that are actually making it so
that we don't have our dependence and
privacy anymore okay we've already used
our thumbprint for years we've already
given our face at this point on snapchat
said enough things to our phone that it
has our voice now right yeah it's crazy
too late now it's too late as gonna
happen it's gonna happen my god it could
be fun it could be like it could be fun
boy if you don't pub gir oh all right so
we're going to Portugal in the morning
Porto car I'm really excited are you I'm
very excited speaking of which quick
shout out to our girl Laura mm LG yes
thank you so much who lives in Portugal
speech
speaks Portuguese and wrote us out cards
och I asked her for help because she's
hardcore dink and hardcore gym yeah we
went to Japan a couple years back and
our friend Ali who at the time worked at
Google did this thing where she wrote a
little card translated into Japanese
because she spoke Japanese about our
dietary restrictions vegan and gray and
it was so helpful cuz all we had to do
is just show them the card at the
restaurant because I'm not trying to be
disrespectful and like you have to
assume anywhere that you go
they're not gonna speak English that's
that's the safest way to make sure
you're not being disrespectful so
instead of going to restaurants trying
to explain in English or like broken
Japanese what we can and can't eat Ali
hooked us up with just a little card and
the Japanese culture is very like they
want you to eat they want you to be
happy they want to help you they just
don't understand where she found that
that method was so so how long so I
Laura did it for us so thank you so much
Laura we love you for that
so some hole-in-the-wall restaurant and
the only person there only speaks
Chinese for some reason no only Chinese
I mean I'm excited I've never been
obviously but I'm excited to see what
it's like and taste the foods and look
at the sights and explore I know it's a
short trip we're not gonna be there for
very long but I do have to say
this is the earliest that we've ever
been like packed and ready feels good
right we're you well because we thought
about it the other day like usually when
we travel like I have to work or like
make a video like we're podcasting right
now but I mean I guess we didn't this is
this is a lot of times like before I
leave for LMT I'll podcast night before
the podcast were able to kind of do the
night before things not be stressful
videos on the other hand right radio
shows vlogs etc those are a lot more
kind of high pressure and so we it's
it's 10 p.m. right now and the clock's
falling back at midnight so it's
basically 9 p.m. right now right and we
leave tomorrow morning and we're feeling
pretty good I mean we got kind of very
close there packed my toiletries are
packed
I'm showered I was spray tan on we clean
dad's dad has a clean cake the house is
clean yes everything is ready to go
Oh guys say something really quick
though because this is off topic of
going to Portugal but I know in my
videos like when I do [ __ ] up things
to myself I sort of do like a mini
follow up like the next week and tell
you how to going or whatever to you know
just to fill you in real quick but now
that I have a minute to explain
something can I tell you I feel like
bleaching my eyebrows has been a more
permanent decision than shaving them not
permanent but like has lasted longer
really like blonde no they're there you
can see like a little bit of root but I
guess I like vastly underestimated just
how long it takes for the entire brow to
like grow out or like fall off you know
like apparently your eyebrows on your
face for a long time before you grow
like new eyebrows oh I see we were
saying so you know so the time it takes
for the color to go to grow out
completely I think it's much slower than
the hair grows itself I think is
probably the same as like the hair on
your head
I mean that's a safe assumption right
it's also very good right now because I
penciled the minute I can't even tell
they look normal but I mean like even
when I showered earlier I like you know
usually I have some brow product in at
some point in the day but I like
showered and I'm like scrubbing my brows
and I look in the mirror and I'm just
like holy [ __ ]
they're still so blonde and when I don't
have eyebrow makeup on I look like an
alien do you want to do that to me I
know that's insane that's a crazy thing
to say I know and I would never I would
that was three weeks ago it's been
almost a month and they're just like
completely blocked like white you were
trying to convince me to bleach my beard
like that be sick yeah but you can just
shave your yeah did you see my beer but
still I don't want to go like I'm just
gonna shave my eyebrows again you know
just shave this okay this takes a lot of
work and love just like eyebrows it's
the guy browse for your chin mm-hmm what
what if I had eyebrows right here just
like I've made my beard into little
eyebrows I'd be sick but anyways I just
wanted to tell those of you that watch
the podcast that also watch my main
channel bleaching your eyebrows is kind
of a commitment that I did not know that
I had signed up for like to grow my
eyebrows back when I shaved them like
after a couple weeks they were like
stubbly like you could totally make him
look normal with a pencil by a month so
they were like pretty good right now I'm
still in a world to hurt that's
surprising because I was actually I did
not expect your shaved eyebrows to grow
back so fast this would be a lot of a
lot more quick of a turnaround it's also
just kind of stupid like I remember
snake was playing you were out of town
you were on LMT
and snake was playing pub G and he was
like you want to play soon and I was
like I gotta go to the store but I got I
need like 10 minutes before I go to the
store I gotta go pencil my eyebrows
because I don't want to go to the store
and have someone be like what's wrong
with you I would feel bad but you like
literally did it to yourself I know a
prank well also like because your
eyebrows do so much for your face like
when they're not there like at all like
they're superblocks your face I look
sort of unrecognized you [ __ ] your face
up like if I were to get ID'd like if I
was gonna go buy some wine I would look
at my ID and I would look at me with no
eyebrows and be like who the [ __ ] is
this you did I'd get out yeah it's a big
part of someone's face it's a huge part
of the zones thing and you've now shaved
them and bleached them yeah I mean I
don't regret it but I I guess I
didn't know or didn't even really think
about how long it would take to for them
to be brown again whoops yeah we live
and learn or live and do it again in
some amount of months what she probably
will whoops
whoopsie you know what I do when I try
though
I used to get my eyelashes like tinted
and like curled apparently can do that
at home you can like curl your own
eyelashes at home whatever I'll just go
blind because I would 100% blind myself
if I tried to do well I used to get my
lashes tinted when I would get them
waxed when I lived in Santa Monica and
the whole process is like your eyes are
like shot in between these two things
and they're putting tint on your lashes
and it like it hurts your eyes like
rinse them out with water like you
really can't get that dye in your eye
obviously so then you're like done and
for like a couple hours they look
amazing it's like you already have
mascara on but then after you wash your
face like one time I'm like I'm gonna
put mascara it's such a waste of time
and energy and money and I pain but
you're doing again at home for a video I
would do it again or I would try and
curl them for a video but I I don't I
also don't want to go blind yeah I would
I mean I'm so furious and how I do
things if I ever tried to do something
like that about a hundred percent injure
my eyeball and probably go blind that's
terrifying you know do it then but I
mean I'm I have to make a video in
Portugal so maybe we check out the the
Portuguese Beauty scene oh my god well I
think that's also part of the reason why
we're so ready for this trip impact
Early's because I usually will do a
video for the day that we're gonna be
gone but this trip we just said [ __ ] it
I'll just do it there yeah it'll be fun
and you're gonna be using the sony alpha
camera i am i didn't pack my DSLR
because that'll be a little ridiculous
convert to the dark side no convert no
shade to sony but um um canon has my
heart sony alpha full life no all of
your files are like they need to be
converted before you can hang out with
them not true at all they just don't
work on your
David Vaughn camera you know don't you
talk [ __ ] about my vlog e because if I
recall you're the one that told me to
get that blog e you got vlog about it
for you honey not outdated it's lovely
it was lovely no I still like it I still
[ __ ] with it hard okay let me just give
you a music give you a little physical
representation of what it's like when my
blog you trying to focus on you just
going back and forth that feels so weird
okay let's focus we move a little bit
stop that's what it does it takes 45
minutes to [ __ ] me
okay but you're right I can't talk to
you there was my first vlog cam and I
have a special place in my heart for it
I hate it you don't hate it focus on me
I love you anyway we have a game that
we're gonna play well it's not really a
game right yeah well it started off as I
was thinking about when I was in high
school and I was in a club called deca
which is basically a business people
club though no smart people and yes
pretty smart people I don't think
there's anyone dim going to deca I mean
that was a smart girl but there were
definitely people smarter there than me
and definitely just people that wanted
to take a trip to like you know Batavia
and stay in a hotel or whatever the [ __ ]
we weekend out of the year it's a thing
but you like you go to a big convention
and your school has a team and you're
like it's like a club so you meet like
once a week or whatever you talk about
business stuff and I was just trying it
out and I did for like a year or two I
think I was the treasurer for my deca so
I think I did like business management
or something and so the club is based
around coin of these like events sort of
I mean you do them together like as
groups like in the club and then you do
it out of convention so then there's
like you know regionals and then States
and then there's like you know in the
country you can go to like the top of
deca and like be really good and once
like the basis of there's all different
categories so like the one that I did
was like management but other ones is
like finance others like you know sports
marketing marketing it's all business
related and it's just teaching young
kids about business and it basically
puts you in fake scenarios I mean others
of them were like come up with a product
and give us like a presentation as to
why we should buy it or create an
advertising campaign even an advertising
campaign
yeah like they were different so I was
in management which meant that because I
didn't know that what management was
first of all my friend was in it second
of all and it was like the easiest one
basically because I asked my advisor
whatever I was like what should I do
she's like just do management and all
right sounds good it like required the
least skill so during the the convention
or wherever the regionals we go and I
think I did win a medal though because
there was almost no one in my category
so I by default came in like third oh
yeah yeah but wrong yeah so you go in
and for the management one they there's
like three or four judges like sitting
at a table and earlier in the day like
they have a you have a specific amount
of time like a half an hour or something
20 minutes they present you or everyone
in the category with the same like
paragraph that like explains what the
scenario is so mine was like there's
this this older guy that's been working
at your company for like 30-plus years
he has three kids and a wife and like
you think things are getting stressful
at home because he has been showing up
late or he hasn't been working not doing
his job properly he's like in his 50s
and what do you do in this situation and
I remember like I just gave no [ __ ]
like I was there literally that kid to
just have fun that weekend and do a club
so that you know I could have something
to do and put on my College resume and I
show up in that room and I'm like look
we got a [ __ ] fire him okay we're
gonna let him go there's so many young
people out there ready to do his job if
he's not gonna show up you're gone and
the judges are sitting there cuz they
can
actresses and they're like well what do
you think about the fact that he's
worked here for so long do you maybe
want to like talk to him or like see
what's going on like now he's fired yeah
my body it and I mean I said it with a
little less confidence than that but I
basically was like get the [ __ ] and um I
think I want a third place to something
by default because there was no one
there but I definitely didn't do well I
wish I could have seen that I feel like
so the tangent bringing it back we
aren't doing that we had thought that
would be a really cool thing yeah I try
to look up like dekha scenarios those
existed on the Internet yeah we didn't
quite figure out like a podcast friendly
way to do it but we still might at some
point and I think we can like formulate
that together with you guys like a good
way to make that on the podcast yeah we
can have those scenarios like you know
mmm sort of like debates and arguments
and yeah I think I'd be fun we're doing
something similar because we kind of let
off that path to the morality quiz yeah
which is what we're gonna do now yeah
cuz we're just looking for like some
scenarios where we could then decide and
argue about what we would do in that
situation yeah and we found the Murata
quiz which I'm right I think is I'm
ready to be judged all right you don't
judge us well let's [ __ ] around a little
bit yeah so don't judge us yeah maybe
don't judge us too hard maybe not all of
its completely real maybe some of its
exaggerated that's true I think you goin
I got it okay okay alright what this is
called all the tests sometimes we can
link it as well but you can you can play
with us if you want it's all the tests
com it's the morality quiz you can play
with us if you want it'll be linked in
the description question number one
mm-hmm all right you were in a lifeboat
with eight other people the lifeboat
can't hold everyone and will capsize
soon the only way to avoid killing
everyone is to throw one person off
about one of the lifeboat passengers is
a grievously injured woman who is
certain to die soon but she's alert and
fully aware of the issue at hand could
you throw that passenger overboard
knowing that you'd be saving the others
and the person saving the others and the
person being thrown off would know that
you were doing it
so isn't this like a classic morality
question it's like kill one person to
save a bunch of other people yeah okay
so the choices are I would not be able
to throw the injured woman off the boat
I would be able to throw him off the
boat I wouldn't be able to throw off the
boat but I wouldn't mind if another
passenger did see is me come be you
would throw up throw her off okay
let's get her up out of here this
question deeply reminds me of I was in
Costa Rica when I was in like 7th or 8th
grade with my family my mom still
doesn't know how to swim and my Aunt
Mary desperately wanted to go whitewater
rafting
which is like it was a kind of an
intense River like it's not just like a
let's chill in whitewater raft it was an
intense [ __ ] River so our boat is
going down it's it's we're hitting a
rapid wind it's getting wild for you a
plane listen my mom is terrified they're
like sit on the edge of the boat she
keeps dipping down into the middle like
not paddling freaking out she's freaking
out the whole time because it's wild the
boats about to flip me and my uncle go
flying off I was underwater for like a
minute my uncle was underwater for like
two minutes dangerous it was Terry I saw
the scar on my hands from Isis well I
was under this like it was against a
wall and so you keep getting pushed
under and under and on your name for
that everyone yeah but the the guide
like dipped a paddle in the water and I
was able to get out but it took a lot
longer for my uncle to get out but if we
hadn't fallen off the boat the whole
boat would have flipped over my mother
what it drowned you know what I'm saying
so I have no problem if somebody goes
off the boat everyone else is gonna live
my mother would has Walmart them just
throw them often I don't want to do it I
don't work karma is real it's not my job
to certain that's the situation so I'm
going needs deserve the comment it might
not give me me I don't I don't want I
don't want nothing to do with it what if
we tow her behind us we can't do that
because these these questions we get her
get her in her injured body
who's gonna weigh our boat down kill
everyone up out of here throw one person
I'm the person that got injured I would
realize that I'm the least fit to be
there okay and get thrown off well
here's the problem we can't throw her
off the boat in like tow or behind it
because she's injured so let's assume
that means like
so she's gonna draw sharks to the boat
maybe we say okay here's a solution we
throw off the back of the boat we're
like just hold on to it we do it can't
support your weight but like you can
swim behind us sharks come then it's not
our fault anymore so you want to watch
her get eaten by a shark then just throw
overboard he's sick yes I'm still
picking sea for the third one okay
you're doing the third one yeah you get
results at the end of this right yeah
you like judges you okay great
I can't wait in another version of the
lifeboat dilemma the person that would
be thrown off was your best friend
mm-hmm your friend was injured due to a
recent car crash oof which resulted in
brain damage she your best friend isn't
fully aware of everything going on would
you be able to throw your best friend
off about knowing that I would save the
others wow that one's a lot more heavy
really quickly me undies great underwear
couldn't figure out a segue there you
need to buy it because it's three times
off in the cotton and it has the coolest
designs anywhere you will not find
underwear like me Elise I'm telling you
go to Mia nice calm look through their
selection they have new designs added
every month
okay bye really great artists and
designers I have a drawer upstairs
overflowing with me undies I can't keep
track of them they are so soft durable
and when you hear the words three times
soft and con you're like I don't know
what that means cotton soft well no it's
not you have to touch it to believe it
it's amazing it's basically like wearing
nothing except cooler okay go to me
undies calm that's n:e undies calm slash
energy only get 20% of your first order
and it's delivered right to your door
you don't have to go anywhere okay
they're living in the future the best
underwear you can buy right now they've
been one of our og sponsors great
product and now they have brought let's
as well as socks
oh yeah as well as more underwear for
women and it's just expanding its
they're just getting started guys check
it out
me and these are console a channel
Julian you will not be disappointed I
guarantee it also check out this skin
the skin is a newsletter delivered to
your email every day with the bullet
points of what's going on in the world
okay so if you were to have signed it
for the skin last week it would have
popped into your email on Monday and you
said okay
the Dodgers decided not to play in the
World Series Game seven they lost and
then you would have Donald Trump got
deleted off Twitter for 11 minutes
things like that where you're like I
need to know the tippy-top important
things I don't need to be dragged down
with all this nonsense it's everywhere
on the Internet
the skin cuts to the chase gives you all
the important information that you need
and it's in a really bite-sized format
in the morning and it's free guys it's
free
you literally subscribe you go to the th
es ki mmm that's the skin with two M's
Tom /gen and Julian you subscribe with
your email and then that's all the work
you you have to do and by doing that
you're entered to win a $250 Visa gift
card it's a great deal trust me
and when you go to work the next day
there will be someone at the water
cooler trying to best you with their
knowledge of the world and you will beat
them and their name will likely be Karen
but if it's not you will still demolish
them with your knowledge that's all oh
yeah thank you sponsor your sponsors
Ernest all right option one is I could
throw my best friend overboard to say
the others option two is I could not
option three is I know it's the same
options as the first good different I
would not be able to throw my friend off
but I also wouldn't allow another
passenger to throw my best friend off oh
they're in different orders for me they
make something I could throw my best
friend overboard disabled that's the
same options there's no more so either
you could throw them off you couldn't or
you wouldn't mind someone else throwing
them off but you couldn't do it yourself
no I would not be able to throw my
friend off but I also wouldn't allow
another passenger to throw my friend
right sorry I skipped that mm-hmm okay
so it's difference either could couldn't
or won't and so check them at all costs
yeah I'm protecting the bus I'm not sick
there your friend I think the part where
it's like they're not fully aware
because they have brain damage is like
enticing you to do it yeah but that no
it's also like the familiarity aspect of
it it's like are you willing to you know
do it if it's a stranger does that
change if you know and love that person
for sure of course it does
I think [ __ ] okay it is wartime and and
for our hiding in a basement is that
supposed to be the number four it just
says fo r it is for time and you are you
I think it's you were hiding in the base
alright it was wartime whatever that
means and you are hiding in a basement
with a group of random strangers enemy
soldiers surrounded the premises and
will be drawn to any strange sound
mobile you better not be in there but if
you are found you will all be killed
immediately a baby starts to cry loudly
oh my god and can't be stopped the only
way to quiet the baby is to smother the
baby to death saving the lives of
everyone else with you the baby's
parents are unknown and not present
there will be no penalty for killing the
baby no no no no no could you be the one
to smother the baby oh my god I could
not I won't be I won't father the baby
but I'm not opposed to someone else
mother you know I could smother I
couldn't smother no way I couldn't smell
okay no way absolutely for me if I
smother that baby I wouldn't even want
to survive that's what I'm saying like
why am I gonna live now I'm the baby's
crying I'm an evil person oh my god
right away in another version of the
baby's dilemma it isn't a random baby
the baby's parents are present in the
basement and since they are present
there will be a penalty but if the
screaming baby isn't quieted everyone
will die including the baby could you
smother the baby with the parents
present no no I can't smell the baby if
I don't the baby will be killed anyways
along with everyone else I could not
swear the baby I would be opposed to
anyone else smothering it - I could not
what about I would be opposed to anyone
smothering it - yeah I'm opposed to that
that doesn't include that you won't
smother I think it that means it's
including it I think it's implied you
know what I mean
yeah I'm gonna pick that one how would
they post I don't want anyone's mother
in that baby to death though it's not
like oh my [ __ ] god
while this gun tents in a third version
of the screaming baby baby no oh my god
I could never smother my own child I
would be fine if someone else was my
baby I could smell you may be able to
save others I could never smell the
problem oh my god you can oh my god if
you're gonna die for a note from noise
being made and your babies making noise
you die with your baby we're all doc
that's it we're all dying what do you
want to live after you okay I'm done
with a question number 6 we're almost
almost out of this an out-of-control
train is barreling down a track towards
five unsuspecting people the train will
surely kill them all you being the
conductor of the Train can throw a
switch diverting the Train to sliding
but an equally unsuspecting man is there
and will also be killed could you throw
the switch killing one but saving five
very classic yeah
I could easily throw the switch I
couldn't throw the switch I would throw
the switch but also try to warn the
suspecting man who will be killed
obviously that well obviously that one
right yeah in another version of the
Train dilemma you and a man are on the
sidewalk next to the tracks you need to
push the man in front of the tracks to
say expecting people on suspense know
what I can't no I can't I could try but
I might not be able to push him in time
I could push the man on the tracks to
save the five others I can't push a man
onto the tracks
absolutely not like in What's in what
realistic scenario though is that a
choice hey if I push this dude onto the
[ __ ] train tracks it'll save those
people no you're like assuming anyone in
the in the train tracks is gonna [ __ ]
die you're essentially adding a six in
there's a very specific set of
circumstances that I can't really buy
into it yeah what the I'm not pushing
anybody Thank You stranger of the
traffic you and your family you're on
vacation your daughter is seven and it's
best friends with your niece who is also
seven your families are very close and
your daughter asks if your knees can
come with you on your holiday you agree
when you arrive at the destination that
girl's asked if they can go for a swim
you tell them the wait until you're
unpacked but they can play on the beach
instead the
human oh this would never happen but
keep going a few minutes later you hear
screams from the beach you run down see
that the girls didn't listen to my first
frame they are caught in a rip and
struggling you see that your niece is
struggling more than your daughter since
she isn't as good of a swimmer
you can save both but one at a time
would you save your niece first knowing
she would probably drown first while
your daughter has a greater chance she
can hold on until you come out again or
would you save your daughter first
knowing your niece will drown I would
save my niece first if she's gonna drown
I try to save both at the same time
that's an option that is an option so
it's I would say my knees first my
daughter can hold on I would say my
daughter first or I am going to try and
save them both at the same time coursing
trying said most of the same time but
beyond that I would save the the child
who's drowning the most first I get it
like would you save your own kid versus
another kid but like think about that
situation rationally you know what I
mean so just drown me it depends on how
confident I am and my daughter so much
question here but like come on now
nananana like we grew up on a lake
basically every summer with my dad like
that's where I broke my nose which was
nobody's fault of my own basically but
like we were not allowed to go anywhere
near the waterfront unless my dad was
with us yeah like there's no like okay
go play on the beach there is defiant
kids in the scenario that's what
happened II don't get it I'm just gonna
stand over them with my pole and be like
[ __ ] you guys same time I'm the option
I'm going to try to say both the same
time to try to save my knees first if
I'm confident my tire can hold on cuz I
feel like that the same time is gonna
both my daughter can hold on
I'm saving my knees first okay if I'm
confident my daughter hold on there's no
point in risking yeah that's my second
choice I'm not gonna let my [ __ ]
knees drown
he's crazy this is a lot darker than I
thought it was gonna be right another
version of the swimming dilemma it isn't
your daughter and niece but it's two
random strangers when you get close
enough you realize that they were your
childhood best friends they've been with
you through everything and you don't
want either of them to die
one of your friends is struggling more
than the other which means they would
have a smaller chance of survival which
friend would you save first the friend
that's struggling more the other one or
I wouldn't save either because I might
get stuck as well the one that's
struggling water easy all right easy
what I don't know you are the judge
presiding over a trial of an alleged
bank robber who you know is innocent
however something terrible in your life
has happened the enemies of the robber
enemies of the rapper have kidnapped
your 9 year old daughter and another
hostage you don't know where she is
the police have tried to locate her to
no avail the kidnappers have left you an
anonymous note saying that if you
convict the robber they will set your
daughter free you fear the kidnappers
could be abusing or even torching your
child what do you do
I wouldn't convict the robber because he
is innocent I would convict the robber
to get your daughter back
I would can make the robber to get your
daughter back
I wouldn't kick the robber but I would
also give the note to the police to help
huh my daughter that one your what
you're like negotiating with criminals
that have a hostage basically at that
point I make the robber I wouldn't I
wouldn't convict the robber you'd be so
desperate to get your kid back that you
wanna take a chance at not convicting
the robber but like who's to say that
you're gonna you're gonna throw an
innocent man in jail who's to say they
even keep their word you don't you have
that option you don't have that that
luxury of playing that game you have to
do what they say what that's how I would
think okay the crime shows do you watch
where I'm like okay people with a ransom
whatever you want that never works out I
would I would be doing exactly that I
was told what the hell if they said
convict the robber and you get your
daughter back I wouldn't do exactly that
what how is that insane I don't
understand how that's so insane you're
doing exactly what you're told to get
your daughter back so you're gonna play
you're gonna play this game that they
want you to play where you're like oh
I'm actually not gonna do this I'm gonna
get the cops on you and then what if
they kill your daughter what what about
the innocent man you're throwing in jail
you go to the cops later once you have
your daughter and tell them everything
and then maybe you go to jail but at
least your daughter's safe okay
I mean that's not the weirdest thing in
the world but
that's also like myself in the mindset
of someone as desperate as someone
you're relying on them even telling the
truth they could have already killed
your daughter but you you don't know
that you have to take the chance because
you have nothing else okay hmm
I would do what they say and then myself
yeah once you say afterwards you'd go to
the police and say I had to convict him
guilty we need a [ __ ] retrial or
whatever I understand that you would
make it your life's mission once your
daughter safe to get that guy out of
prison yeah okay number one yeah okay
all right test results I'm scared hmm
what'd you get for 40% wait I don't get
it
just read it for 40% you are you
wouldn't be able to cause charm to
others even if you this is [ __ ] is this
charm for 40% I guess I got 40% meaning
you wouldn't be able to cause harm to
others even though it would be
beneficial so I'm weak and then what's
the other one 56% of the 18,700 69 quiz
participants had this profile oh wow
what did you say I got for 60% you are
in the middle and try to find a solution
that causes the least harm that sounds
like me so I was like weaker so to speak
than you were only 23% of people had the
same answers isn't it interesting I'm a
verb go see what we do is we analyze all
the situations and we go the path of
least home but I'm not even mad about
that because I know it's accurate
because I'm putting myself in these
hysterical situations where I know I
wouldn't be thinking rationally you just
like think how you think for what you
have written funny mmm
what a dark quiz I know there's a lot of
those I know they get really dark yeah I
had a feeling I was gonna get kind of
dark I'm all set with the smothering
baby questions
yeah that's I'm good are you [ __ ]
kidding me um spoiler alert if you've
not watched Ozark quick Ozark reference
I haven't watched oh well you don't care
do you hmm no I mean I kind of explained
it to you anyway but anyway there's this
scene at the end where it looks like
he's drowning his baby but he's not he's
dad was christening the baby
right that's what they dip him in the
butt it was like the darkest looking
scene for a while and you're just like
what makes that [ __ ] me up anyway yikes
not to end it on that note
oh yeah actually we won't be in town
tomorrow which or tonight which means we
won't be streaming tonight normal Monday
streams well tweet it out though too
just in case you guys are like hey guys
where's the Monday night stream but
we're not and we're not gonna be
streaming because we're gonna be in
Portugal and tell ya we probably know
anyway until
anyway thank you guys for being here
like I said earlier if you have an idea
for how we can do some sort of deco
scenario where if you are in Dec there
you were in deca and you have those
prompts yes I do it we don't um thank
you guys for hanging out we'll see you
guys in the next one and have a great
week bye guys
[Music]
you
[Music]